[Music]
hey this is Mel strong and this lecture
is on the carbon cycle and more about
greenhouse gases so this is a
continuation of the greenhouse gas
lecture so if you haven't watched that
watch that one first and one of the
things I'm going to be doing is talking
about how carbon moves around in
different reservoirs around the earth
and so I'm gonna use some illustrations
that I made that are on my website or on
the learn if you're one of my students
and I'm going to illustrate them feel
free to print yours out and illustrate
it the same way we talked about how last
time the last lecture that there are
several greenhouse gases there's a bunch
of greenhouse gases and some of them are
really strong but of all the ones that
we worry about co2 is the number one gas
that we're concerned about just because
as humans reproduce more co2 than
anything else by far okay and so we
worry about methane we worry about
nitrous oxide but we really worry about
carbon dioxide because we just invent so
much of it so that's what this lecture
is about it's a mostly about co2 and so
we talked about where the co2 is and in
the atmosphere it's in the form co2 but
it can actually that co2 molecule can
can move to different locations like
maybe the ocean or maybe in a plant and
it's no longer in the form of co2 it can
change to a different molecule so we
keep track of the carbon part of the co2
so we talked about the carbon cycle
ultimately what we're trying to get at
is that co2 is in the atmosphere and
something is putting it into the
atmosphere something is removing it from
the atmosphere and it's being stored
somewhere but it's not necessarily
always in the form of co2 it could be
some other carbon molecule
okay so to start out with we're going to
talk about something called the
reservoirs of carbon okay this is where
the carbon is okay where is it being
stored around Earth and I'm going to use
a unit here called the teragrams and we
abbreviate it as TG oops
okay a teragrams one teragrams is one
times ten to the twelfth grams and what
that would mean is you'd have to move
the decimal over twelve places so for
example if I had three teragrams that's
the same thing as three times ten to the
twelve grams which is the same thing as
three one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve zeros right
put some commas in there and the thing
is this is such a giant number like you
can't really wrap your mind around what
that even means and it doesn't matter
because the point of doing this is to
show relative sizes of which cart which
reservoirs are bigger and smaller but
they're going to be in this unit of
teragrams so for the numbers we're going
to write down remember just add twelve
zeros to everything if you wanted to
write out the number okay so the carbon
we are concerned about is the carbon in
the atmosphere and it's in the form of
co2 and that number is currently about
829 teragrams okay now by comparison if
you added up all the carbon of all of
the plants in the world
you get about 600 teragrams
okay so these are if you look these
numbers up you'll get slight variations
on this so these are kind of mutually
agreed-upon numbers more or less right
okay then in the soil because soil
there's a lot of living and dead organic
material in the soil and that
a lot of carbon in it soil is about
2,000 teragrams okay now the ocean
there's a lot of carbon in the ocean and
it can be in a couple forms it could be
in the form of dissolved gases so what
that means is anytime you have gas
sitting above liquid there is exchange
between the two so there's co2 dissolved
in the ocean just like co2 is dissolved
say in a soda okay so some of it is in
the form of that some of it is in the
form of organic matter so in other words
anything living in the ocean so dead or
alive it's got carbon in it okay so add
it all up you get about thirty eight
thousand tera grams of carbon in the
ocean now notice so far that that
reservoir is so much bigger than
anything else we've written up here okay
that's just gigantic okay so there's a
lot of carbon in the ocean now this
diagram I have I made here shows
carbonate rocks down here what does
carbonate rocks carbonate a lot of times
we have this compound called calcium
carbonate and a lot of organisms have
this in their shell so if you find a sea
shell a clam shell for example it's
going to be some version of calcium
carbonate and there's that carbon that's
in this molecule well when that animal
dies sinks to the bottom of the ocean
gets buried that carbon is now buried in
this what we call carbonate rocks a lot
of it is microscopic organisms that you
actually can't see these are little
microscopic plankton that foot in the
ocean they have calcium carbonate
skeletons even though they're
single-celled microscopic organisms and
they they die they settle at the bottom
they make this this carbonate mud that
gets buried and so a lot of carbon ends
up getting buried in these carbonate
rock
now here's the kind of the confusing
thing is that a lot of these carbonate
rocks are no longer in the ocean because
they're spread all over the planet on
different continents where the ocean
used to be so we don't have time to go
through the geologic history of all this
but there are many times in geologic
history where for example the United
States was covered in a shallow sea and
so we have lots of carbonate rocks all
over the country all over the world that
are not in the ocean anymore even though
they used to be in the ocean so if you
live around Albuquerque you look up at
the Sandia's you see these little
horizontal stripes at the top those are
carbonate rocks those used to be at the
bottom of the ocean the ocean wasn't up
there those rocks were down below sea
level at one point okay add up all the
carbon and all the carbonate rocks in
the world and you get a pretty gigantic
number about 80 million teragrams okay
so so that number Dwarfs the one we just
wrote so most of the carbon in the world
is tied up in these rocks which again
started out in the ocean but they may no
longer be there and then the number two
reservoir is carbon in the ocean itself
now we also have in my picture here we
get fossil fuels right and so we can
break that up into let's see here we got
coal it's about 3500 oil about 230
natural gas about 140 and other forms of
fossil fuels about 250 and you add this
all up and you end up with greater than
about 4100 teragrams okay so let's
compare these numbers by far biggest you
know by far by far our biggest in the
rocks but let's just leave those aside
for the moment because that carbon is
pretty much stuck there the carbon in
the ocean is the biggest reservoir by
are the carbon in the atmosphere is the
one we worry about the most because this
is related to the greenhouse effect
notice how much carbon there is stored
up in fossil fuels compared to the
amount that's already in the atmosphere
right so there's way more waiting
underground that we as humans could
potentially burn and use and turn into
the atmosphere right turn into
atmospheric carbon okay so this is sort
of a simplified look at the reservoirs
where the carbon actually is I'm going
to start with another diagram just like
this and we're going to talk about
processes that are going going on here
okay so for this next diagram we're
going to do something about fluxes okay
and a fox
in this case fox is something that's in
motion foxes in this case is carbon
moving between reservoirs okay so the
last one was reservoirs where is the
carbon being stored now we're looking at
how is the carbon being moved back and
forth between some of these reservoirs
and that's off what a fox is okay so
we'll start with some that you probably
already know so you learn for example
back in your days in biology about
photosynthesis okay
so the general formula for
photosynthesis the general reaction is
plants take co2 and they take water and
they take light and they produce glucose
and oxygen right this is what
photosynthesis is all about this glucose
molecule if I were to if I were to write
this out and balance it the way that a
chemist would like I would have six co
twos
six waters and then I have this glucose
molecule six oxygens okay so the six is
just that's just to balance it when we
talk about the carbon cycle I said
earlier that we're following carbon
around and we're worried about co2 in
the atmosphere but it can change its
form and be in other molecules other
than co2 so here's an example what I
mean by that the carbon was in the
atmosphere as co2 okay and then the
plant puts it into plants tough plant
matter glucose our carbon just changed
reservoirs it went from the atmosphere
to the plant right so that's a flux
we're taking out of the atmosphere we're
putting it into some biomass okay so as
long as a plant is photosynthesizing
during the day it's removing co2 out of
the atmosphere okay so what I'm going to
do is draw these fluxes and different
colors so vegetation I'm going to draw
with a green arrow and what's coming in
from photosynthesis is about a hundred
and twenty three tera grams per year
okay so this is photosynthesis okay now
the plant continues to live when the Sun
is is is not up because plants like us
have to respire so even though they are
producing oxygen during the day and
they're using up so you know that point
co2 out of the atmosphere during the day
there's a secondary process that's going
on twenty-four hours a day and it
it only goes on it's the only process
that goes on during the night but the
punts are doing it 24 hours a day and
it's called respiration respiration is
what we would call breathing okay we're
breathing in oxygen for letting us co2
deaths respiration we do it animals do
it plants do it and and so if we write
out that formula for respiration it's
basically the opposite of what we just
wrote for photosynthesis okay so we
would have the glucose plus oxygen we'll
get some heat out of this reaction some
co2 and some in some some water vapor
and and so now what's happening is the
carbon that is in the glucose is being
transferred back into the carbon that's
now in the air right so this is this was
in the plant this is in the air this is
in the air okay this is in the air right
so photosynthesis we take the carbon out
we put it into glucose respiration we
take the carbon out of the glucose we
put it back in the air it's basically
backwards now we're doing the same thing
even though we're not plants we are
still taking a carbon from glucose and
we are exhaling co2 all right okay so
but just to focus on plants for a second
so what that means is there is this for
the synthesis that's removing carbon
from the air but then there's
respiration that is putting it back so
this is plant respiration
okay so 50 teragrams is going back out
into the atmosphere so the net that
plants are doing here is there is
they're bringing in more carbon than
they are producing as long as the plant
is it's growing so this is a worldwide
average for all
the vegetation on earth okay okay
now speaking of respiration down here in
the soil there is a lot of things that
are living in the soil I mean have the
root systems are respiring you get
microorganisms that are respiring so
there's respiration going on in the soil
and that is contributing carbon to the
atmosphere as well so I'll use a purple
color here and that is about 70 point
for teragrams per year also so let me
just put down soil this is respiration
and fire so fire is the same reaction
this is also the same reaction for fire
except fire it happens faster but when
you're burning a plant you're taking the
carbon from the plant matter reacting
with oxygen getting co2 and water vapor
okay so respiration and fire is the same
reaction just respiration as slow fire
is really fast so if you take all of the
naturally-occurring respiration in the
soil and all the naturally occuring fire
you get about 70 point four teragrams
per year going out back into the
atmosphere well now you've got I've got
a little farmer here and I can't fire
and whatnot and this is to simulate what
humans do we call this a land-use right
so if we cut down trees we put up a
parking lot we build houses we make
roads we pile fields we burn things down
that's collectively called the land-use
okay and land-use there's actually we
could break it down further like if I'm
a farmer and I and that plant crops
those crops we'll pull down the co2 out
of the atmosphere but when I take
everything to an account so the planting
of things plus the burning of things
well you know all of that combined
it turns out that we add about 1.1 tera
grams per year and this is called land
use okay land use all right we will come
back to this in a second let's talk
about the ocean so one of the things I
said about the ocean a minute ago is
that there is gases that are going both
directions in the ocean so you have
gases going into the ocean and you have
gases leaving the ocean so I'm gonna
call this gas exchange and so you have
the you have the experience that if you
take say a soda and you twist the top
and then see what two comes bubbling out
right that co2 is dissolved into the
liquid right so you can take gases and
you can dissolve them into liquids and
in or pour glass water
set it down come back the next day
you'll see little bubbles on the inside
right that's gas that is coming back out
of the liquid so this is happening with
the ocean there's gas going into the
ocean and there's gas coming back out of
the ocean and what's going into the
ocean is about 92.3 teragrams per year
and what's leaving the ocean is about 90
tera grams per year okay so there's a
little there's a little more going in
and there is coming back out and we'll
come back to that in a minute and then
finally we have our fossil fuels here as
we burn fossil fuels - like we said in
the last lecture mostly generate
electricity transportation we are adding
about 7.8 teragrams
per year okay all right so we talk about
sources and sinks what does that mean
sources is where we're adding co2 to the
atmosphere that's a source a sink means
we're taking it and we're putting it
away somewhere underground or in Iraq or
in a plant and that's a sink okay so
we've got sources and sinks all right
going each direction so if we and by the
way this is simplified there are there
are many other smaller ones I'm just
trying to paint the big picture here so
the next diagram is going to be what is
the net result what is the net result of
all of this all right so for this one
we're looking at the result of the
previous previous diagram of fluxes so
if I take all those foxes the sources
and the sinks and I do the math and we
see where ultimately are the changes
occurring overall every year there's
about 2.6 tera grams of carbon going
into the world's vegetation okay so
every year that goes by we're adding
more carbon to the world's forests to
our farms anything that's growing okay
now if you remember from West's from so
just a minute ago we were looking at the
last diagram we had over here that there
was two arrows going up and down from
the ocean and the net is that there is
about 2.3 tera grams per year going into
the ocean all right so there's gas
exchange some goes that some goes into
the ocean some
out of the ocean but there's a little
more going in than there is coming out
and so the net is that 2.3 teragrams per
year are going into the ocean we'll talk
more about that in a second and then the
atmosphere is gaining about four tera
grams per year okay now this is the
number this is this is the thing that
we're worried about the most okay
we're worried about what is the effect
of these increasing co2 levels right and
that's what you've been reading about in
my class this is what we're going to
keep talking about but let's talk about
this one first what does it mean to keep
adding this much carbon into the into
the ocean every year all right what does
that do so one of the things that it
does is if I take carbon dioxide and I
react it with water I will get a
compound h2 co3 which goes by the name
of carbonic acid this is a weak acid co2
in the presence of water turns into a
weak acid if you had a really bubbly
soda and you're trying to drink it out
of a glass or something you may have had
the experience once in a while that your
eyes burn a little bit like when it's
super fizzy that's carbonic acid so
every year we're dumping 2.3 teragrams
remember that means times you add 12
zeros to the end of this is going into
the ocean and that co2 that goes into
the ocean you may have read in our
textbook that it's a good thing that the
ocean is taking up some of the co2
because that means there's less of it
for the atmosphere but it's a bad thing
because we're making the ocean more
acidic the oceans
or overtime or becoming more and more
acidic because of this now why is that a
problem so let me show you a couple
pictures so when you think of a coral
reef this is probably what you think of
it there in Showell
usually warm water a lot of very
colorful organisms and I want you to
notice that it's in pretty shallow water
here maybe a meter or two below the
ocean's surface and there's a lot of
different organisms that live on a coral
reef so we see we've got CNN CNN amis
here we've got starfish we got sea
urchins with all kinds of things but
they're all living on this big mound in
the background and the mound itself was
built by these little organisms called
corals and these look like plants but
they're actually colonies each one of
these has a bunch of little tiny
individuals living inside and the coral
is each one of these little animals and
they secrete a calcium carbonate shell
essentially that binds them all together
until like this giant apartment complex
and each one of these guys is an
individual so corals are related to
jellyfish they have these little steamed
tentacles they sit there they do this
waiting for something to flow into their
mouth there are pretty simplistic
organism but they're important because
this calcium carbonate a house that
they're making forms the basis for work
all those other organisms that you saw
earlier are going to live now
even though corals are animals they have
living inside their tentacles these
little single-cell photosynthetic
bacteria called zooxanthellae okay so
this is what they look like so there's
one of the tentacles of the coral and he
sees all the green spots each one of
those green spots is a single cell for
the synthetic organism that generally
cannot survive on its own outside of the
coral so this is kind of confusing
because the coral is an animal but
living inside the animal are these
little plant like things that are for
this in
and they're producing energy that the
coral itself is using okay so they have
this symbiotic relationship the nothing
is going to eat the zones in thely
because they're sitting inside the
stinging little tentacle here and the
coral itself gets some energy from them
in order for this to work the coral has
to be about a meter below the ocean
surface right so if the coral gets out
of the water - huh you have gets out of
the water that's not good the coral dies
if it the water is too deep there's not
enough for the synthesis that's also a
problem so they'd like to be about a
meter or so below the surface well when
a coral gets stressed for reasons that
not I don't think are totally understood
the the coral will reject all of those
zones and thely
and they turn white and this is called
coral bleaching
so this coral right now is stressed what
would stress it higher temperatures will
stress it or if the ocean becomes more
acidic that will stress it out and so as
we have been making the ocean more and
more acidic and warmer and certain in
some respects we're seeing more and more
bleaching of corals and so in some
places we see this big extent of coral
bleaching now these these corals again
this is the first stage on their way out
so they will reject the zone cynth le if
conditions improve then they will come
back and things are okay if conditions
continue to deteriorate
then the corals will die okay so not all
these corals in these pictures are
necessarily dead yet
here's some before and after pictures of
corals that are now bleaching and we see
big chunks of coral reefs around the
world starting to do this this is the
bad sign it tells us that the oceans are
now becoming inhospitable for the corals
and the corals form the basis for these
coral reef ecosystems here's one that's
finally dead so this one has bleaching
and then conditions never got better and
the corals finally died
here and now they kind of turn this dark
color so when you see here if I go
forward here's an example where some
coral this is the coral is bleaching
just starting to happen you see a big we
Qing event here the following year and
then later the corals are all dead and
turning this dark color so that is one
of the reasons why we worried about the
amount of carbon going into the ocean
we're producing carbonic acid that isn't
is stressing out the corals the corals
form the basis for these coral reef
ecosystems so we're seeing these big
bleaching events so a hundred years ago
or so scientists thought that we might
be adding carbon to the atmosphere but
no one had actually measured it and so
people speculated that you know we think
today people talk about global warming
like is this new idea but you can find
scientific papers a hundred years ago
where they were speculating that this
could happen but we didn't really have
any good measurements of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere so finally in the
1950s a guy by the name of Charles
Keeling decides that he's going to build
a machine that's gonna measure carbon
dioxide and he's gonna build a machine
that takes a measurement like every day
and we're gonna start monitoring
monitoring it over the long period and
see if it changes so in order to do this
he needed to find a spot that was away
from cities that was pretty you know
hopefully up in the atmosphere he wanted
to get them the most the cleanest air
sample he could and so he decides that
he's going to do this on the Big Island
of Hawaii and so Big Island of Hawaii
has two volcanoes manalo Mauna Kea
they're both over 11,000 feet tall and
so at that time there wasn't a road up
to the top Ernie no electricity or
anything like that this is a this is a
pretty big project but what he managed
to do starting in 1957 is he built an
instrument and he put it on the top or
near the top of one of these volcanoes
mono Lola and here
picture what it looks like up there
you're actually above there's a cloud
layer that forms over the ocean this is
stratocumulus so we talked about earlier
in the semester you're above the strata
cumulus on most days and this is a sign
that's up there today so that's at
11,000 141 feet and right now there's a
lot of equipment up there but back then
this the very first thing that they were
measuring was co2 so he builds his
machine he turns it on in 1957 and he
lets it run and it runs a couple of
years and he looks at his data for a
couple of years and he finds that there
is this very odd pattern where the the
co2 goes up and then it goes back down
again up and back down again up and back
down again but as it's doing that there
is this very slow rise over time okay so
we're going to talk about this this
graph is called the Keeling curve there
is no Nobel Prize in meteorology or
climatology or environmental science or
earth science but if there was if there
was ever a Nobel Prize in this field
this graph would get it first okay it's
such an important graph it actually has
its own bronze plaque and I don't know
of any other graph that has its own
bronze plaque okay the Keeling curve so
we're gonna study the Keeling curve
because it is so fundamentally important
to environmental science and what we're
talking about here okay so we're gonna
have a look at the Keeling curve and on
the axis on the x axis is time and on
the y axis is co2 now you'll see for
example on this one it says parts per
million
okay so there's not much co2 in the
atmosphere but we have a way of
expressing it so if I had three parts
per hundred okay we would call that
percent can we use this symbol right so
the math would be three over 100 okay
that's percent there's another symbol
that you probably not familiar with
where if you had three parts per
thousand
that's called per mil and it has two of
the circles and you would do it you do
three divided by thousand okay if I have
three parts per million the way I write
that is 3 ppm and if I did the math 3
divided by a million okay so on this
graph that we are going to look at here
the y-axis is usually in ppm parts per
million
all right so a couple years after
Charles Keeling turns on his machine and
he starts to get data this is the this
is what he sees
he sees this up-down pattern I might try
to focus and he also sees that this this
up-down pattern is gradually increasing
and he knows that this is pretty
significant so there's two things going
on and we got to separate them out first
is what's causing the up-down pattern
okay now on earth we have what we call
deciduous trees these are trees that in
the spring they bud out and as you start
to grow there's a growing season the
leaves get bigger in order for the
leaves to get bigger the plant has to
pull co2 out of the atmosphere okay
so throughout the summer the deciduous
plant the sigils tree whatever it is is
growing growing growing growing and is
pulling carbon dioxide out of the air
and it's making you know from
photosynthesis so then coming to the
fall the deciduous tree loses its leaves
the leaves follow to the ground now that
carbon that it took out of the
atmosphere a lot of it is now laying on
the ground in the form of dead leaves
and all the microorganisms are munching
away and digesting that and that carbon
goes back up into the atmosphere so in a
normal year for a particular if you
think of just one deciduous tree in the
spring and into the summer the growing
season it's taken co2 out of the air in
the fall in the winter it's actually
adding co2 back into the air because
it's dumped off all of its leaves okay
so now imagine a set of one plant doing
that
imagine all the plants in the world
doing that so because the seasons are
reversed when we have summer in the or
let's say spring in the northern
hemisphere our plants in the northern
hemisphere are starting to bud out and
they are sucking down co2 out of the
atmosphere but at the same exact time
the plants and the southern hemisphere
are experiencing fall and their leaves
are falling off
and that's adding co2 to the atmosphere
so the two hemispheres the plants and
the two hemispheres balance each other
out but when you look at the two
hemispheres what you see is that there's
way more land in the northern hemisphere
than there is in the southern hemisphere
okay so what does that mean that means
that there's more plants in the northern
hemisphere than the southern hemisphere
so that means that when we're talking
about competing seasons then nor the
plants in the northern hemisphere are
the ones that actually are in control of
the carbon in the atmosphere because
there's more of them so even though
these you know if the hemispheres were
perfectly balanced if there was the same
amount of land in each and the same
amount of plants in each as one was
losing its leaves and the other was
budding out leaves the two effects would
cancel each other out they don't cancel
each other out because we've got more
plants in the north okay so if we could
so thinking about that then if we
consider this this up and down is being
controlled by what the plants in the
north are doing right so let say we'll
start in the fall and the leaves fall
off in the fall and they fall on the
ground and that returns co2 to the
atmosphere so that means that where we
see co2 increasing that's starting in
the fall and it continues throughout the
winter in the northern hemisphere in the
northern hemisphere okay so the seasons
I'm writing are northern hemisphere
okay so co2 gets returned gets returned
gets returned and then we finally get to
the spring and things start to bud out
and as they do they start pulling co2
out of the atmosphere so we get into
spring and as we go down this way this
is the growing season and into the
summer and then it repeats again fall
into winter etc so this up and down that
we're seeing that's due to plants and
it's due to the plants in the northern
hemisphere because we have more of them
okay so that's the first thing Keeling
notices but the second thing Keeling
notices is perhaps more important than
that which is that this whole pattern is
on the way up and he realizes even after
just a few years of data that this slope
is due to us to humans burning fossil
fuels so this is the human co2
contribution that's adding on top of
what the plants are doing so you can
kind of think of it like this if there
was a world with no humans we would
expect that it would do this it would
cycle with the seasons of the northern
hemisphere because of the because again
of the plants but it's doing this
instead because every year we are adding
more
to the atmosphere and so every year we
progressively add more and more and more
so here are some data from Hawaii just
the last few years okay and you can see
there's this the red the up and down
those are the seasons and then this
black line is sort of a mathematical
average over time and I go forward one
more here
so here's for example just the last few
measurements of the last few days when I
write before I recorded this we have
surpassed 400 parts per million now for
a couple of years and as seasons as you
know right now we're going into the
northern hemisphere spring so we should
actually expect some of these numbers to
start to go back down here a little bit
this is what it looks like today up
there there's a lot of instrumentation
they're measuring all kinds of stuff up
here that at the center for
stratospheric research is what they
called and so I actually went there a
few years ago to do some research in my
own and this building right here that's
the building that has that bronze plaque
on it so here's another picture of it's
this right in here and this is all this
is really awful in mr. the public is
just scientists you know super nerds
walking around here but if you go inside
this building this is what it looks like
and there's this box right here in this
really old chart recorder and you open
it up and there's a piece of plexiglass
here and this is one of the original of
this is one of the original machines
that Charles Keeling made is technically
not the first one because the very first
one I guess got taken apart but it's
essentially the first one so all the
scientists they are I go oh my god they
get so excited you can see my reflection
taking a picture of it in there but this
is the first a co2 monitor
since Charles Keeling put that in on the
top of Hawaii we've been putting them in
all over the world and it's the same
pattern everywhere
it's that same up-down but climbing co2
so one thing we'd like to know as
climate scientists is how much
greenhouse gas was in the atmosphere in
the past whether it be co2 or methane or
whatever so we have killings machine
that's been taking measurements since
1958 but how much co2 is in the
atmosphere say 100 years before that or
100 years before that so there's a
couple ways you can do it some people
have found sealed bottle old bottles
with air in it and analyze that so maybe
you find an old bottle from you know 150
years ago you can analyze the air in
there but further back you go the harder
it is and so one of the ways that we do
it is if you find a place that has been
frozen consecutively without ever
experiencing any melting that you can
actually find trapped atmospheric gas in
the ice so snow itself fresh snow so if
you're a skier think of like some fresh
powder that's like 90% air but then
after the snow sits on the ground for a
while it very slowly starts to
recrystallize
and that fluffy snow kind of gets gritty
and granular and then eventually it
turns into something called fern and if
it's a place that never ever actually
melts what'll happen is those nice
fluffy snowflakes eventually turn into
solid ice and the air that fell as snow
gets encapsulated as a little bubbles so
this is what it looks like so the little
bubbles in this ice our old trapped
pockets of atmosphere the atmospheric
gases from when this ice first formed so
this piece of ice is a thousand years
old
then the bubbles in there are little
samples of thousand-year-old atmosphere
so this only works if you have a place
that never gets above the freezing point
right stays frozen all year round so
there's two main places that we can do
this one is Antarctica and the middle
Antarctica never melts and middle of
Greenland
now there's also some places you can go
and do this on the continent where you
have glaciers year-round those glaciers
are disappearing but people are still
trying to sample them so if you want to
do this you get yourself some Russians
because they really like the cold
they go out to a place like Antarctica
and they set up these geodesic dome tent
things and they drill down into the ice
so this is specially designed drill to
drill down into the ice and remove what
we call an ice core so they're trying to
recover the ice without destroying it
and this is what I score looks like so
they'll drill down thousands of feet and
keep removing ice and the ice that they
remove when they pull it out and polish
it you can see the individual years so
in a place like Antarctica you only get
a couple centimeters of snow a year but
it just never melts and so each band is
a year and the bubbles that are
preserved in each band have a little
sample of the atmosphere from that time
when they were that ice formed so what
you can do is if you drill down enough
you can go down thousands of years you
can extract air thousands of years ago
and they store this ice in these giant
warehouses that are kept below freezing
so each one of these tubes has an ice
core in it now let's say your site I
climate scientists you know I I would
like to find the atman samples of the
atmosphere 50,000 years ago so what you
do is you go to one of these facilities
and you find ice that's 50 thousand
years old and there's a whole set
with saws and everything everything in
this warehouse is kept below freezing
and you cut out the ice you're
interested in and you seal it in glass
and then you melt it and then the
bubbles come out and it's sealed in this
glass that you put it in and then you
extract the gas out and you analyze it
so using this technique we can actually
recreate the atmosphere all the way back
several hundred thousand years so
Antarctica has been below freezing for
several hundred thousand years so in
this graph what they've done is they've
reconstructed co2 parts-per-million
and here is today now this graph has
made a few years ago
so today the co2 level is higher it's
kind of like up in here now but they
went back now this graph goes back says
400,000 years and then it says for
650,000 years atmospheric co2 was never
higher than this level so we can with
with Antarctica we can actually go back
pretty close to a million years before
you run out of ice when we extract the
ice and we analyze the gases what we
find is that for the past million years
we've never seen co2 as high as it is
today ok now you see these big patterns
right so here the co2 was pretty low we
were in what we would call an ice age
here the co2 was higher so that so earth
was warmer then we've got another Ice
Age warmer these are natural cycles and
there's changes in the Earth's orbit
that caused this okay so we're not
worried about that like this is we know
what does this what we're worried about
is this that we now have more co2 in the
atmosphere than the earth is seen in the
last million years or maybe more and the
question is what is the earth going to
do how is the atmosphere going to
respond we can also look at other
greenhouse gases so this is years ago
I think it got cut offs it's time to
forked 2005 when this was made and
they're looking at methane and now
they're looking at ppb parts per billion
they're getting it out of the ice so you
can see from about ten thousand years
ago to pretty close to the present day
there wasn't a lot of variation in
methane remember methane is a pretty
strong greenhouse gas there's not much
of it in the atmosphere but it's a
pretty strong gas and then starting
there and they're zooming in here is
what they're doing starting about you
know 1900 or so we see a big uptick in
methane so methane is probably higher
now than it's been in the past million
years or if you remember from the last
lecture another a strong greenhouse gas
is nitrous oxide again parts per billion
there's not a lot in the atmosphere that
you see some error bars so it's it's
there's more uncertainty in the
measurements but again back ten thousand
years ago
the amount of nitrous oxide stayed
pretty constant until we get to again
about late 1800s 1900 and it starts to
take off again that's higher now than
it's been in the last hundred thousand
year our last million years or so so one
of the things they've done is
reconstructed what we call the
pre-industrial atmospheric concentration
so we talked about the industrial age
that roughly correlates to like 1800 ish
or 1850 different definitions of
industrial revolution but sort of when
humans started with steam engines and
burning a lot of coal C 1850 we'll just
use that as a number co2 is about 280
parts per million so in other words if
the industrial revolution didn't happen
in all the things that humans have done
since then didn't happen we'd expect the
atmosphere to have about 280 parts per
million and as we just saw a few slides
ago it's currently over 400 they've also
established some other ones methane
nitrous oxide few others but these
numbers here the pre-industrial amounts
that is what
the concentrations should be and then
these numbers here are what they
currently are and actually this is
already obsolete so they're even higher
than what is what is shown here
so in conclusion whether you look at co2
or methane or nitrous oxide we've got
more greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
right now
then the earth is seen in the past about
million years maybe more what's going to
happen and the short answer is we're not
totally sure so we know that there are
natural variations in greenhouse gases
so we saw the co2 go up and down in the
past but it's never been as high as it
is today so one of the questions is what
is the climate system going to do and
we're going to talk more about this in
the future lecture but one of the big
worries is we're not totally sure what
is going to do we know things are
warming up we can predict how they're
going to warm more in the future but
could there be something else that's
going to happen and we'll talk more
about that in a future lecture all right
thanks
you